hello everybody i'm josh welsh president
of film independent and welcome to
today's coffee talk i am so excited
uh that film independent can host this
conversation today between two
remarkable writers
uh the writer and filmmaker sandy tan
and the novelist ellis batuman
um
really looking forward to the
conversation today before we get started
i just want to say um
thank you to all of film independence
supporters for sustaining us through
this critical
year going on two years whether you're a
sponsor an art circle member or a member
thank you for
thank you for being part of the
community um if anyone is tuning in who
uh drawn by these two incredible writers
and who's not familiar with film
independent we are a film arts
organization based here in los angeles
to support the independent film
community
we're an open access organization so go
to our website check it out and please
join because we do lots of good stuff
all year long um with that i just want
to get right into this
please join me in welcoming first of all
uh the writer and director sandy tan
hey sandy hey
and uh
also joining us the novelist uh elif
bachmann elf
hello
hey
great to see both of you thank you for
being here
thanks for having us
so i i'm gonna
cut out of this room in a minute but
before i just want to tee this up by
saying um
i love my job because i come to it as a
fan of great work whether it's writing
or filmmaking and
the opportunity to have conversations
with with
artists and creators who i admire and
love their work and today is certainly
no exception to that i am a huge fan of
um
two novels here which i'm going to hold
up dorkly
the idiot by elif and whoops
lurkers the new novel by sandy tan
um they look good together they do look
good yeah um
uh i just i i suspect many people tuning
in for this conversation we'll have
already read both of these books but if
you haven't i urge you to go read them
uh and of course i suspect everyone
tuning in has already watched sandy's
amazing documentary shirkers but if you
haven't you have to go watch it
i will say
one thing um
fans of one thing i think you both have
in common is people who like your work
in my experience do not like your work
mildly they are tend to be fervent uh
uh
admirers or fans of your work and and i
feel the same way um
with regard to sandy i at the risk of
embarrassing you sandy i hope it doesn't
but
uh richard brody is so passionate about
sandy as a filmmaker um
in the new yorker he uh you know last
year i think came out with a list of top
documentaries and he picked shirkers as
one of the best documentaries of all
time and then during covet in the last
few months he came out listing the best
performances of the century so far and
sandy herself is makes his list of best
performances um ray but i love this
she's placed on this right between bill
murray and lost in translation and
tiffany haddish and girls trip which i
think really captures it
yeah my correct taste level um but but
that was that's insane insanely generous
and and that made my my
um the plague worthwhile for me
yeah
um and ella
you know with the idiot um
it's a novel that again if people
haven't read it just go out get it and
read it go to in your local independent
bookstore and get the book and read it
you will love it this is a book that
people who have read it
quote either at length or pulling
individual sentences out that they just
can't stop quoting
and um it's
smart funny moving sprawling epic and
unforgettable
um so
we've come together with sandy and ella
because uh excitingly they are working
together on an adaptation of the idiot
um
and with that i think i'm gonna
duck out of the room and turn it over to
the two of you to talk uh
about whatever you would like to talk
about
oh good we can talk about cats
no no i will oh just two things before i
go uh please if you have questions put
them in the q a button down at the
bottom um i will come back uh after 30
to 45 minutes and
um we'll bring up the questions there
and and we'll continue the conversation
at that point so until then i will see
you both shortly
thank you
thank you
as i was saying to um to everybody i
think um ellis and i we text and we
email quite a bit in the past few years
but we hate talking on the phone like
most most people nowadays and um so this
was like my excuse you know when josh
asked me to do this i thought it was a
great excuse to kind of say hi to her
and catch up and you know yeah i haven't
seen your face i think i saw we met
twice
and yeah that's it i don't think i've
ever even seen it yeah before before the
plague yeah because we you just don't
zoom it's it felt too weird to be doing
when i'm working with your words every
day
i'm inside your head it'll be so weird
to come outside and then see you and and
have things not
you know cohere
but yeah that must be really odd to be
working on something where the person is
like alive and like you you know them i
was trying to think what that would be
like and it freaks me out so i stopped
thinking about it but but you are doing
that because you're you're you're you're
working on the sequel to the idiot which
most people would be very excited to
hear about
uh over here and then um i
well i one of the the thrills for me i
think we talked about a few days ago um
of
working on the adaptation of something
uh you know by somebody who's living is
that i can actually tap you for answers
when i'm stuck um when i'm writing a
scene say um where i have to bring them
out the characters out on to on like
onto a picnic feel and and then i i have
to give selling something to eat and i
just want to be true to her because my
whole thing is to be completely true to
you know you um and um
and and then i ask you yeah because the
line is quite blurred between me and
like sometimes i feel like i'm answering
based on something that's in the i've
really enjoyed these correspondences
where sometimes you'll write with a
question for something like once it was
spelling his last name or sometimes you
were driving around boston and you sent
pictures of buildings and you were like
was this the building or like does this
look right and then there was the that
one that was like making up um what she
would bring to a picnic where svetlana
had a baguette um
and uh and i was kind of like why isn't
still on giving her the biggest like so
it was like
um because some of the things are things
that i've thought about like with
people's surnames and then some of them
were things that i hadn't thought about
and some of them were things that were
in the sequel and for some of them i was
kind of going back to my idea of sit-in
but then for some of them i'm just
thinking about myself and i feel like
exactly but that's what i'm interested
in because yeah because i wanted to make
this thing kind of true to you now as
well as true to you back in 1995 which
is when this book was set so then
there's that kind of slightly meta um
feeling to it too
and but your answer invariably when it
comes to food is nuts
it's always nuts
yeah and it's like so i have her eating
pistachios and you told me this fabulous
anecdote like your aunt and you being
obsessed with pistachios yeah
yeah we would just we would in turkey
over the summer they there's like you
can get these untip pistachios that are
like really just fabulous and we would
just obsessively because we you'd always
have jet lag too so we would just and we
we um live far apart in america so we
would come to ankara and we would just
sit all night
and pistachios until we got like
fingernail infections like thumbnail
infections from opening them which is
quite gross actually this was the word
you use
was it fungus
fungus
it was really gross and and that was the
um that was that was so striking that i
had to put it into my voiceover for you
oh great so it's it's in there i mean i
hope it makes it into the the actual
film but it's in the script
um because i i just thought it would be
fungus though okay yeah infections
i think it's infection i think um but
anyway whatever it was it was gross and
it was in there
and um it was very much a part of i
think being true to you
thank you i really appreciate that what
a great gift this whole collaboration
has been
um
so
you know because one of the other things
about the book and adapting it and what
drew me to
to want to make this into a movie is
that it doesn't seem
like a natural fit for a movie
you know i mean it's it's not it's
perfect it's a perfect book
um but it's not necessarily dramatically
structured for a movie so that was kind
of a challenge to me and really a fun
puzzle
um and i really appreciated having you
to ask whenever i had things because you
do these very obscure little things in
the book where you say um that um
you know like um
yvonne sent me an email and then it made
me feel this way but you never would
reveal what was in the email and then so
i had you
i could actually ask you um you know
what was in the email or you know
sometimes like some some of the more
obscure uh things that you had in the
book and i just couldn't get you to draw
it out and to tell me some of the
secrets
oh yeah i remember that being really
helpful like when we kind of made up an
email together because actually um the
first draft so i wrote the first draft
quite close to when everything
um happened it's based quite closely on
my life from my
six and i sort of turned it into a book
a few years later in like 2000
um and then i started editing it like
just you know in 20
i don't know 16 15. yeah it was over 15
years so yeah it was a really long time
yeah um and then uh
and i was on a contract to write a
different book and then i turned this
book in instead and um i didn't know
what the editor was going to say she
actually had relatively few um
edits but one of them was um there's too
much of yvonne like we hear too much of
this guy she's like i get that those
emails were like would be great to steve
if you but like for us now like just
really frankly the less we know the
better
and i think that was true but like
that's i mean it's it's a part of um i
also thought the idiot was not
necessarily adaptable like i had some
interest in other from other filmmakers
but people were like oh how would we do
it would be too much voiceover so i um
yeah i was i was really
flattered and amazed when i saw shirkers
and thrilled that you thought it could
be done and were so enthusiastic about
it um it's super cool but it's the
constraints are super different because
like
i mean you're we were talking about this
a little bit too like your your toolbox
is just so different like
in a book you can you can just say that
someone sent an email and show the
effect and have the person thinking
about it and like ruminating it and it
reminds them of something else but like
it's not um
i don't know i've been thinking and
there's there's a little bit of henry
james in the sequel and he talks about
he wants the most exciting scenes in
portrait of a lady to be when she's
sitting in a chair like realizing how
just [ __ ] she is because her life is
all messed up and like he's like it had
to be as exciting as it um pirates
surprising the island but like you can't
really do that in a movie like you have
to or you have to show something else so
it's just been really interesting to
hear all the things the details that you
have pulled out to make um yeah and
incidentally um gene campion's
portrait of a lady is one of the best
films ever made i think
oh i've never
yeah it's it's just great i think it's
the best film
um it's just amazing but anyway it was
yeah it was it was the it was the puzzle
of finding you know
teasing out these aspects because also
like watching two people typing on a
computer is like the most boring thing
in the world so to find solutions to
that creative solution so that becomes
like you actually um make it more
exciting as well uh for yourself and
maybe hopefully as a as a story and as a
film and um finding all these you know
visual motifs that you can do in a movie
that you can't do in a book and and just
finding the
um
the filmic um
you know relative of what you were
trying to do
in the literary way and just being true
to your vision but using say um there's
this thing that you throw away in the
book um i think we talked about this the
pink hotel that she does as a school
project where she you know papers her
dorm room full of
pink construction paper and makes it
look like this pink hotel that um she
remembers from a trip to mexico with a
mom when she was a younger teen
and um and then and then they asked you
what what did that look like because it
you mentioned it so fleetingly in the
book but it sounded like it's it's
something special because it's um you
know papering your entire dorm with with
pink computer paper it has to look
slightly striking um so then you sent me
these amazing photos and they were like
a wes anderson film they were like
stills from a wes anderson film or
something it was like you know you and
right and this everything in your dorm
room was bright pink
except for you i think in it and and
and i just thought you had to put that
in the movie i mean i had to with the
movie and and have her you know turn her
dorm into this thing which
as a way of exercising something that
happened to her young you know in in her
in the younger days when she was trapped
in this pink hotel with her mom
um and then and then to use this pink
hotel as a motif throughout the film as
as um you know a state that she's trying
to get out of
um like i feel so moved when you talk
about the pink hotel because it was
really important to me at the time and i
was i was like obsessed with that hotel
for ages and i was actually i mean i
loved movies when i was that age and i i
thought about maybe taking a filmmaking
class and i just didn't because it was
so expensive and the people who did it
were just always in that basement
you know there wasn't digital yet they
were just in there cutting up film and
you never saw them again and
that was extra money yeah so and you had
to like work with other people and i was
like no i'm better off just you know
sitting at my
computer um and i didn't do it and then
i don't i don't know and then
and then my sensibility changed and i
kind of lost touch with all of it but
like that was what that was how i saw my
life then like i saw it as a movie and i
you know like
just
almodovar meant so much to me at that
time and then when i saw shirkers like i
recognized so much of your sensibility
like a more developed a more visually
developed version of the sensibility
that i had when i was younger and
there's something about your stewardship
of the pink hotel and you bringing it to
life that it's like i almost don't like
to think about it too much because it
just makes me so emotional to think that
like if someone told me when i was 18
that like this really cool filmmaker who
like you haven't even met yet and she's
like i don't know where now like in
singapore and england now and she's
gonna recreate the pink hotel and put it
in a movie like i would have completely
flipped out like you just can't well
because i saw that in your book and i
just knew that it meant something to you
but it wasn't fully drawn out and i had
to kind of tease it out of you like i
had to bug you for those photos i had to
bug you for details and that was kind of
the fun of doing um you know this
collaboration which um
you know just not showing you the actual
script i'm working on but actually just
asking you for information and you know
like making it as true to you
maybe even truer than you expect or
realize or that i would do necessarily
because like i'm still embarrassed about
all those stuff like it was embarrassing
exactly
they're like and they're like my 18 year
old art project it's like yeah i know
but it's it's it's amazing and poetic
and you know i think you would be too
close to it to um describe it too much
because also describing a pink hotel you
couldn't do it too much on the page
because it wouldn't seem
vivid but on screen you can just bring
it to life and then you know as a motif
and as well as um the music that you
mentioned that you were you know stuck
listening to when you're trapped in the
pink hotel which is um el binoni's
adagio right and and we kind of
use that as a you know we're planning to
use that as a motif through the film as
well like you know all the way from the
organ grinder um you know kind of a
conversion of that to a disco version of
that depending on where she is and what
state of mind she's in and and then
slowly she begins to escape that you
know
at first
an overplayed piece of music and
especially in movies like that there was
just that manchester by the sea where
like he's carrying his children's
corpses out of a building and was
playing that and i was like oh that kind
of never but then but then i thought
that like by very virtue of it's totally
something that you could hear someone
play on an accordion on a street corner
like you hear a music version somewhere
like it's so replicated it's um yeah
and it's also funny because it's so it's
it's really funny yeah that's so that's
why i love it because it's it's so
discordant um it's automatically funny
yeah it is funny always makes me laugh i
love the use of um kind of funeral music
in a kind of a funny teenage situation
it's just funny
um
but anyway so yeah so all these things
that i probably saw because i was a
teenage girl too um maybe still am and i
could see that you were trying to do in
the book um but they weren't quite um i
mean that it would try to articulate
even further in in the film version
because you can do that in the in the
film as as opposed to the book so let's
have the second half of the film version
would be in europe um especially hungary
and that's where her world you know we
begin
you know like kind of like in that very
cloistered um college
um
you know malaya and it's it's it's funny
but it's also very um it's such a hot
house and then and then the world starts
to you know the outside world seeps in
it's almost as if it's like turning into
technicolor or something and and the
screen is widening and the sound design
is more you know it permeates her her
life much more she's noticing things
she's noticing that it's spring
where where before she would just have
your you know her walkman on and just be
listening to whatever she listens to um
and i just love what you can do with
cinema but um you may not be able to do
in books but also as a writer i love
what you can do in books that you can't
do but it's really different it's i was
i mean in in the sequel too there's a
part she um the end of it is in turkey
and briefly
but the whole beginning is in boston
again and just that feeling because a
lot of it is about kind of the idea of
different countries and like nationalism
and what that is and people being from
different countries and what does that
even mean and like
um
yeah so but just the extent to which you
go to a different country and just
everything looks different it's you
can't completely convey that and like
you have to find different ways but it's
like a workaround it's like you know you
can't
without a voice over
like interiority or like interior
monologue you know you have to find a
workaround and film like you show the
person's expressions or something like
that but it's it's exactly the same
thing and you can't
i don't know you realize too when you
read older books like they don't always
describe the things that you want to
know like they don't tell you like the
whole materiality of all of the things
that would be that would have been
different if you're reading a book that
was set you know that's set in a
different country or that was said 100
years ago like just that granularity of
detail like you can't see it and that's
something that just film can do so
not effortlessly because it's all
obviously composed but for the viewer
it's effortless like you see it all at
once but you do you do you do you get so
granular which is what i love about the
hungry sections i mean it's like
it's it's like the best kind of notebook
vomit you know
i mean it's like you describe the all
the signs um outside people's houses
beware of bar um biting dog you know and
and like the elder flower juices that
you know some living history museum old
ladies are making
um and it's it's just so detailed and
it's so like
when she starts when selling starts to
know these notice these small details
that's when her world is coming alive
again it's like her noticing the flower
is the daffodils springing to life you
know but she has to go outside of
herself
um which means often outside of
which is familiar with which is outside
of cambridge outside of um the us into a
foreign land and then these things kind
of
i hadn't talked to you about this but in
the sequel there's a scene where she
goes to um she's working for let's go
this guy the student travel guide and
turkey um and she goes to konya and she
goes to the mausoleum of rumi and she
was never into the poet rumi she's like
wasn't it some like lyrical ecstatic
stuff about like mystical union and wine
and like i'm not interested in
transcendental states that are beyond
exceeding the limits of language or
frankly i don't really care about
anything that exceeds the limits of
language and then she gets a book of
rooney and she's like wait this is the
person who's described who's only true
descriptions of spring that i've ever
read and it's like spring arrives
there's a knocking on the commentaries
on the heart arrive in seven volumes and
she's like that's it that's like that's
that's spring but yeah something about
just realizing spring when you go to
another country just made me think of
that
that's great you know and that's another
funny thing about us is that i haven't
actually shown you um
my final draft and i haven't read yours
yeah so we've been working
protective of each other kind of mutual
respect um move that at some point we're
gonna like exchange manuscripts yeah
totally this is so exciting
it is and i was always wondering like i
would when i would see writers whose
work was adapted i was like well how did
they how did they do it were they like
getting up in the person's grill all the
time were they like really anxious and
then i just feel like the way that
you've done it has been it's been
wonderful like i'd love to kind of have
you ask questions that i can kind of
like guess where you're going but i also
really like to like feel like it's it's
your project and i can just tell from
the way that you talk about it like like
he's just said with the pink hotel
like sometimes the way that you talk
about yvonne like you think about him
differently than i do which is like
completely correct and completely like
actually sounds really productive for
for the movie like it just it's just
really nice to think that you have your
own way of thinking about it and then i
get to kind of be a part of it as sort
of like a fellow traveler but like
you know it's it's a different work of
art with a different sensibility it's
been really exciting so far and
hopefully true to you in the end
i mean yeah because
i mean i'm just impressed by how much
that that's like a concern for you and
how much you talk about that i i really
appreciate that and and everything that
you say
sounds
true like even i don't know like with
yvonne some of the times where you were
like describing like
how he's like kind of cruel to her he's
sort of like jerking her around like
obviously that's true and like i wrote
it that way
but like i didn't completely phrase it
that way to myself like there's no way
you know but like and in fact and and
he's so charming that you you're kind of
doubting yourself half the time which is
the whole idea how it is when you're
there exactly yeah i mean that is the
appeal of this movie for me is that it's
not a straightforward um
bad guy movie because he opens up her
world he actually gets her to go out of
her room and go swimming with him go for
it you know for a walk and then they go
to hungary and
she goes to hungary and it's um
that's what other people are they like
these doors that open up for each other
and they never go all one good place or
bad place
yep
that's what i love about it and that's
why i wanted to do it because it's so
not the usual light white um this is a
bad guy um you know this is a bad
gaslighting guy movie it's it's so much
more than that um which is i think
closer to so many more
so many more people's experience what's
what shirkers too is too like that
sketchy guy
you guys made this beautiful movie that
is on the performance between bill
murray and tiffany
yeah okay but yeah
um but it's um
but yeah so
that was uh that was my my attraction to
your work and um can you can you tell us
a little bit about when we can expect to
see either or
the sequel to the idiot which is also
set over um one year right it's it's
yeah it's one it's the next year it's
the very next year i i started wanting
to write it as soon as i was recording
the audiobook for the idiot so like um
the i turned in all of the stuff like in
the
the galleys came out like in the summer
of 2016 and then i started recording the
audiobook in january 2017 like a few
like before the trump inauguration so
like everyone was in shell shock and
then i
tore during like trump and me too and
then i went to italy and there was like
they were having this like latio salvini
moment there and like it was just this
like constant just never ending anyway
so that's um that was the process of i
just realized um sort of from doing the
promotion at this weird time that like i
understood the idiot better i understood
like one avenue that the idiot had been
going on that i hadn't fully explored
and i was like you know i haven't made
myself clear i'm just gonna write
another book and it's um
it's gonna start that next september and
end the next august so it's it's quite
similar to the idiot it's the school
year and the summer and um i just turned
it in uh actually my editor just
accepted the revisions last week so i
should have a pub date very soon but
okay and she's still hung up um she's
still thinking about yvonne right last
time we talked yeah well she's hung up
about yvonne but she doesn't actually
meet him in this volume but um
she does um
he does hurt her
i'm sorry he does haunt her still
yeah he haunts her and they're still
sort of emailing and i don't know
spoilers don't really okay don't don't
don't don't
don't don't spoil but really don't
um
later okay well can text me we can talk
on the phone but
let's not spoil it for people maybe okay
um i'm curious i'm very curious
well look i won't say who it's with but
she does have sex
um multiple times so that's okay that's
kind of about yeah
okay cool um
it's about so like like part of the the
two kind of
questions that came up in reader
responses to the idiot that i hadn't
been expecting were like why didn't you
write about sex and and also why didn't
you write about alcohol and why didn't
you write about like campus rape and
stuff like that and i was like oh that
never hurts me and then why why is satan
so uninterested in politics and i was
like she's not
where did you get that idea and then
they're like well when she reads the
newspaper it's all about this you know
elephant insemination and i was like oh
yeah i know she hates these papers but
anyway so in the sequel it's like you
see there's more about what she thinks
about newspapers and it's um i don't
know so you respond to rita comments
with yours yeah well yeah i i did a lot
in this one because also it kind of i
don't know all this stuff happened like
i turned in the idiot and then like i
became a lesbian so then and then i got
really into sex wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay
rewind a little bit for the sake of
audience
yeah um
yeah so i i turned in the idiot and um i
turned it in at the end of
2016. at the beginning of 2016 i met um
the woman with my hope to spend the rest
of my life who's in the next room um and
i think
i i hope i'm i'm
i'm done with men and uh it radically
reorganized my way of thinking about
myself and my past and the world and i
started reading like i read so a lot of
the as the sequel is kind of just kind
of rewriting or rethinking something
because it's there you know like one of
my editors said about that and it's not
like i've never thought you know it
never occurred to me until i met a
person and i was like well i'm a lesbian
at least of course this was like
something that i've been thinking about
and like it's they're an idiot that
there's these you know
she and svetlana are holding hands at
the gay pride parade and then svetlana
drops her hand and she's kind of like
why didn't you draw my hand
and there there is this kind of like
like one of my old editors not the
editor of the idiot but the editor of
the possessed editor of the idiot and
he's like isn't this a book about
someone who's just really like not that
into men and which is kind of like a
controversial take but but it i mean
there's that too
um
so then i realized you know i read
shulam at firestone for the first time i
read a whole bunch of adrian rich
because he was you know married and had
three kids and then became this you know
around 1968 coincided with around the
time that she turned 40 which is also
what happened to me after i turned the
idiot i turned 40. and then um
i read this essay by adrian rich called
compulsory heterosexuality which i had
been thinking about in terms of when
people ask me why didn't saline and ivan
have sex an idiot i started to think
about just this narrative imperative
that the girl has to have
that like sex a sexual relationship with
a man is the only thing that turns a
woman's life into a story
why hasn't anyone written about that and
then i found this essay by adrian rich
and in some way she talks about the
different forces in society that make
feminism look lame or that make
relationships between women look kind of
like tame or not that exciting and like
you know make it look like women really
just need to be [ __ ] by men and that's
what has to happen and it's natural and
like um
she's just kind of describing the spill
of goods and how like the greatest art
in the world is reinforcing it and i
understood that that's what like i went
to college and i was like i'm not going
to get married and have children like
what am i going to do i'm going to write
novels i'm going to read the greatest
novels what happens in the greatest
novels these you know anna karenina or
tatiana and eugene and negan they're
kind of like their lives are sort of
ruined by these isabelle archer and
portrait of a lady their lives are
consumed and ruined by men who are not
really as good as them like they're fine
not not isabelle's guy he's not fine but
like bronski and then again they're okay
there's nothing wrong with them but
they're just like not up to the level
but like
the women's sort of like investment in
them becomes the subject of great
literature
i feel like i really internalize that in
some part of me i mean looking back i
think the idiot was eugene and negan
fanfic in a lot of ways that um she saw
yvonne and she was like yeah he's this
kind of like byronic guy and and
um
and what's the problem she projects so
much on him i mean that's that's
the interest of the book i think is a
lot of women have done that
yeah totally and and she knows that
she's better than him but she just
doesn't care she's like what's the i'm
gonna like hang around looking like it's
what is this a test and um so so this is
about how i sort of like de-politicize
myself through my love of literature and
sort of silenced my own queer and
political conscience because
consciousness because those things in
the 90s just did not they were not
presented to me in a way that seemed
appealing
and so that's what i either are is going
to be yeah that's what you know
over over the course of
that year that year which is 1996 to
1997.
yes exactly
cool
yeah so she kept all these you know like
she hears a little bit of funnyism or
psychoanalysis and like she's like okay
what's this what's equity feminine and
she like hears about she's like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] like okay so
i'm just like so curious about your
powers recall because that's a long time
ago so did you have copious um
like you know
well one thing i did i i remembered the
books that i read then so i that i
hadn't reread since that time so i got i
i reread either or i reread nanja by
andre britton i found my old copies with
the underlinings in it and that got me a
lot of the way to remember that stuff
and then some of it was actually
material that i had written
um that didn't make it into the idiot
that i'd written back then some
notebooks it's just copious lots of
notes
i know that i know that you you keep
emails from like 1996 because i've
you've sent me some of them
um
but that's that's amazing what how do
you keep
like
all this stuff from those days i mean
floppy well i don't know not floppy
disks but you you keep i just have a
very small i don't have everything every
email from that period i have so this is
like was kind of like a project that i
was keeping diaries and writing about
and like i would lose parts of it as i
progressed but like there was a giant
file on the computer where i was working
on this novel in my 20s
and um and that file got there were no
disks at some point
um like in the in the arts there was
already there wasn't quite the cloud but
microsoft had some no no i was i was a
grad student for a long time so i had a
ftp i like uploaded a bunch of stuff to
the world server and then from the scan
server server it made it onto something
called skydrive which microsoft had at
some point and then from skydrive it
went on to like wow drive into 2010. so
it's like it's such a pure distillation
i mean it's not a distillation but in
fact a pure download of your brain yeah
at that point yeah so that's amazing
because most people wouldn't have access
to
that kind of level of accuracy
you know that level of detail but you
you're so true to yourself back then do
you feel sort of recognition
yeah do you do do you think it's i mean
when does it inspire you this this
recognition or is it makes it more
distant because you're quite a different
person now
i mean the thing that you described
before where you were like it was like a
brain download like the sign that said
barking dog like that's totally
something i wouldn't notice now and i
that was in an old draft that i hadn't
read in years and years because like i
was embarrassed and i didn't want to
think about it and then when i saw that
i was like oh yeah that's what it's like
to be alive then like you're looking at
every sign and you think this must mean
something interesting and important and
it like it seems really cool it seems
really funny
and um
and there's just this like part of you
that's always like looking around for
some imaginary person and being like can
you please right now like can you even
believe this and by now it's like yeah
yeah i believe it
looks like it's okay but um but yeah
looking at that stuff wasn't able to
make me access that stuff i also started
um like
psychotherapy for the first time in 2014
which i think made me able to access a
lot of stuff and and maybe this is
before the idiot
yeah but so i started i i
did the idiot in 2015. i started therapy
in 2014 i resurrected the idiot in 2015.
i did
those edits for a year i turned it in
2016 and it came out in 2017. so it was
all sort of a
process and um i think like i had a lot
like most people i had a lot of like
self-hatred and embarrassment about my
younger self and therapy really helped
with that and just making it seem like
bro like you know that's who you were
that's it's like garbage and garbage you
know that's what went in that's what was
coming out like
it's just nature
so yeah
and so you you're still tapping to that
old ftp
for stuff
um i think i've probably exhausted it by
now i'm sorry i've been talking so much
how about you no no no how about little
sandy how are you in touch with her how
how is how's that going
that movie that movie is on netflix and
richard brody has seen it a hundred
times
um but but it's um it's that's that's
that's done and i there are aspects
of
my younger self that i'm trying to i
guess um
you know exercise by by writing about
and thinking about so that they can i
can continue in this process of growing
up and one of them is probably you know
trying to get the idiot made um and
that's that's in progress you know we're
in having very interesting conversations
we're deciding
with people so we'll see um
exciting um yeah i just can't wait i
can't wait i'm just like you're eager to
go um
but so so that's that's that's that's
what's happening but
and then you're and then you're gonna do
book
three as well you're gonna start in book
three you said
yeah i'm gonna do i still haven't
decided so this book was already not
supposed to be book two it was supposed
to be something else but um
uh yeah at some point i'm thinking that
i'm gonna stop writing novels and just
be like elif and write some kind of
essays but um i found that my tone when
i write as myself is like quite annoying
i'm trying to make it less annoying but
i think that the tone of like a bit
obsidian is like a little bit
less
yeah i think we're waiting
more
i i find myself annoying too which is
why i was making sure because it was
very very difficult writing the voice
over it was just very very difficult um
just having to see and hear yourself
it's just yeah
troubling thing
um which is why we you know try to do
other things and which is why i try to
you know try to speak in other voices
for instance like trying to channel
yourself exactly like they're doing the
voice over now of yourself then like
that was what i had to remember when i
was like editing the idiot it was all
like
you know i turned it into some kind of
novel when i was 23 and there was this
like 23 year old voice in there that was
like oh when i was 18 i was so young and
stupid and like that was what i had to
like get rid of yeah but it's like but
when i try to write about like i don't
know i've been trying to write more
about like
political consciousness or whatever but
if you know then it turns into like i
used to think like this and i you know i
was so blind and now i'm so smart and i
see all this stuff and it's just um i i
felt like i got a lot of nuance just
going back to that time and being like
you know i wasn't i was quite limited
but like i wasn't dumb and i wasn't
curious and i wasn't like not paying
attention so like what was actually
going on um so from that in that respect
i think maybe i might keep doing that
for another book i'm not i'm not sure
that might turn out to actually work
better than um being now oh
hello hi josh hey you guys i'm i'm
jumping back in the room i hate to
keep going this is no no no this is this
is i think we've reached a natural
breaking point zoom is so strange i've
been like
you know out of the room watching you
and totally engaged in the conversation
it's like i feel like i'm in the room
but then i'm obviously not but now i am
um and we have a lot of questions um
coming in
some of them are general and some of
them are very specific and i want to
start with some of the specific ones
uh where is this one um
super specific question to sandy this is
okay
about lurkers why does ducky call
raymond bryce when he gets the gun i've
been posting oh my god this is so this
is so specific it makes me feel like
it makes me feel like i might have
missed a major revelation or something
does mr z share an identity with raymond
do they have a relationship
um
wow this is a deep one i i had this um
notion that they had known each other i
have to actually go back and look at
this bit um
myself because i forgot it's been a
while since i've read it um
but i um but
i think um
no not mr z but i think um
oh yeah mr z yes mr z did i think live
in
his house no oh
i think it was actually pluto that might
have lived in in um his house anyway uh
you caught me out here i'm i'm so
like there's so many little bits that i
was trying to
who asked this question by the way i'm
so curious
uh
anonymous oh okay
i will get you um
i i i i that's a very good question
that's a really really good question
i'll have to go back and see
but yeah there were all these um there
are all these bits i cut out from the
original um drafters i mean one of the
earlier drafts where you know there were
all these overlaps and i think that i
had um pluto living in
in um raymond's house before
um but mr z that was just a kind of um
echoes i guess i was also going for
echoes so
okay
um a question for both of you also
anonymous
now that some time has gone by since
sharkers and the idiot went out into the
world has your attitude you were sort of
talking about this i i feel uh has your
attitude towards your adolescent selves
changed at all do you find yourself any
more or less sympathetic to or
understanding of that person
you go first ella
that's a lovely question
um i mean so much of the process of
writing it was about coming to terms
with my adolescent self i guess the the
most wonderful
surprise for me
with the idiot was hearing readers
respond to their i remember i was at a
bookstore and the bookstore owner who
was like
a guy maybe like 10 years older than me
like in his in his 50s was talking about
how when he read it
he was able to stop hating his freshman
yourself and like it was such a
surprising thing especially for like a
man like he was a talk for a tall older
man to say i was just like kind of blown
away but and then i got a lot of like
responses from um
younger people now
who are reading it and um
[Music]
i i
i'm sorry i don't have anything to say
about that except that those
interactions are really emotional for me
in a way that i didn't expect and i'm
still thinking about and that they might
have some bearing on my adolescent self
but in a way that i haven't completely
formulated yet and i'm happy to turn
over to sandy
i i think i worked out my adolescence um
making the film um during the process
yeah so i yeah you know like so i
finally grew up like in my 40s i finally
stopped being a teenager i outgrew
that part of my life it was my way of
saying goodbye like you know getting all
this thing all these things
kind of bundled up in this one piece of
of digestible
um 97 minute movie that that somehow
seems to really speak to
young kids around the world and i keep
getting um these letters from um you
know young young
um
kids i guess and
especially places like latin america um
and spanish-speaking countries for some
reason as well and and and and and they
always feel like i'm you know how did i
know to tell the story of their lives um
and i just i that hearing that as well
like like with life um hearing that from
other people kind of like
takes the burden of you know of having
been this teenager and having not grown
up enough um of
me i guess and just having other people
kind of go through this with you and
alongside you and you're all you know
holding hands and going through this
together somehow in some strange way and
for it for for the film to kind of help
them alleviate their own you know trauma
or pain or whatever
has been such a great thing that i feel
like it's it's all you know i'm fully
i'm fully done with being a teenager now
so a slightly related question uh this
comes from somebody named brandy uh and
it's for both of you how do you go about
writing teens and tech emails texts
social media etc for screen novels
without it being cringe i think you've
both done it well
you go well thank you thank you
um
well
you know it was funny because i
at the time that i wrote the first draft
of the idiot it was um it was much
closer to when it happened so
the tech wasn't really that different
the internet was just changing so fast
then um
and it was when i was editing it i
started to look at it like the so the
idiot opens with her getting her first
email account so that wasn't originally
the opening that was like
in it and i just got to that and it was
just the way that she was relating to
email and not really understanding what
its role was going to be in her life was
like so different and that was when i
kind of realized like oh my god this is
a historical novel you know this is like
a book that about when i was in like
when sandy's talking about like the
budget for the film like oh it's a shot
and period i'm like how is that period
but like but it is so um
so i think part of the uh
part of the ability to write about it is
that i didn't realize i was writing
and now when i'm in this in the sequel i
talk about some like some other
developments like she's uh there's unix
talk which plays a role and like that
finger command it still plays a role but
like i still really remember what it was
like to discover those things and it it
feels kind of different to like it feels
kind of similar actually like learning
stuff like i feel like i'm always just
learning new things like how to find you
know stuff from
images satellite images from google or
you know to identify different places
like it's always some
learning curve and um
i just feel like that's still very easy
to tap into the finger the finger is
something that i i come to
come back to in in my adaptation of your
book um my i just love that it was
written in 1995 and it's just the first
our first
this is when the moment that which we
were becoming
us now this is when people were
discovering the internet and you can be
a different person online than you are
in real life which is now taking for
granted and that's that's that's one of
the things i really wanted to capture in
the movie versions like this is the
first contact this is the first
you know like people discovering that
you can be different people and what
that does to [ __ ] up your lives
um and so um in writing this into the
movie
you're you know
showing people playing typing on the
computer is like some of the most boring
um things we can do on screen ever um so
we would invent different things of um
having her start typing but then she's
actually in a different scene or you
know um
you know hearing the voices being read
out the letters being read out um by
somebody and also just seeing
um and this is a spoiler i guess that's
when she's typing and yvonne answers
really just talking to the screen
because it's how she hears him it's like
he's talking directly at her looking at
her you know in the eye because it's
that intimate and it feels that intimate
because back in 1985 this was such a new
thing to have an immediate response
from somebody on online is such a direct
and almost like terrifying and
intoxicating thing and i want to just
want it to capture that intoxicating
spirit of it um and hopefully we will do
that in the movie
it also really democratized not like
i'm writing a lot about um like just her
not having the internet like she's
constantly having to go to the library
or like ask people to find the right
person to ask for advice the basement i
love the detail of like how in the in
those days in 1985 the computers were
put in the basement buildings because
the tapping of keys was thought to be
too disturbing to non-computer users
totally but like a lot of the a lot of
people doesn't have the same access to
knowledge and like you you're you're
more alone in the world or you were
describing that scene where she did a
cell phone which i think where she's
like stranded in the middle of nowhere
and i think that looks different now
than it did back then like it looks
scarier now and maybe reveals how scary
it actually was then just because then
it was normal like it was just normal to
be completely alone in the world and not
know anything and not be able to find
anything in a book like she's always
like running to the liquor store because
that's where they have the cliff notes
of shakespeare because like she doesn't
know what's in some shakespeare play and
yeah that actually made me feel really
grateful that things aren't like that
and like happy for people who are young
now who just have so much access to
knowledge they don't have to like ask
some freaking gatekeeper every time they
want to know something
sandy i have a question for you about
your in your approach to the idiot um
i don't know if this would be a spoiler
or not but like in sharkers sharkers is
so visually rich where you have all
different types of media
you know it's the old footage footage
right
it's a very textural film and i'm
curious are you when you think about
your
with the idiot are you envisioning it
yeah there's going to be a little bit of
that yeah to to kind of bring out
especially on the stuff that's online
um and and as we have discussed the pink
hotel that she
um
you know built in her dorm room would
come back more much more with the motif
as well
um and it's kind of clutchy when you
describe the difference between the
europe part and the boston part too that
that's like yeah
i don't want it to seem too much like a
teenage scene as well because i want it
to be much more universal and less of a
quirky little movie um
[Laughter]
so so the it might seem a little bit
more of that inside her head um when
she's in harvard when she's in the first
part of the movie where she's very much
in the world online you know and and
partly um the appeal of going to europe
with
um selling when she goes out to europe
is that she's not online there's no
computers there as you you know if you
notice that there's no computers there
so she starts to know this thing in the
world and it's a lot less of that
kalanji effect of being in somebody's
head
so she's noticing stuff that's in the
world and the magic's all out there the
interest is all out there people are
interesting all of a sudden because
you're noticing them and not just
reading things on the page
um and that's that's how the world um
begins to intrude
um just because the world is there and
she's starting to notice them
i just have like a totally random
question which was did sandy did you
watch sex in the city when it came out
i was just thinking about that time and
like how
um i was just like when you were talking
about people typing i just remember
seeing that at the like come out in the
late 90s and yeah that it had that the
main character was a writer and like to
dramatize it i remember she would be
saying like she's wearing a tutu and
like one leg is up here and she's eating
a popsicle and she's like something like
voiceover
but i think it um it popularized
voiceover yeah it must be extremely um
thankful i guess i mean you know because
that's one of the first things you learn
when you go to film school it's like no
voiceover
and then and then you start to watch all
these great tv shows or european movies
and they're filled with voice over um
yeah so you know it's a matter of i
don't know like a balance money balance
but also like um the voiceover kind of
recedes a little bit as she goes
as she lives and she starts to really be
alive and
stop it becomes a european movie
yes wow
very specific question for elif uh from
someone named chelsea which bridge in
cambridge is the less romantic bridge
oh man um
i don't remember it's the one that
shoots you out at the business school um
yep sandy did you go there yeah i did i
did like
i i called you yeah all these locations
i sent you photos and and then you would
say no no this one no no that one
and then we found the right ones and
yeah that's the last romantic bridge
it's the one that's very easy to run
over and you won't trip but then you
said that some kids have taken two like
jumping off it or something and then
somebody else told me that
but it's so shallow the charles is so
shallow at that point
that if you're drunk and you happen to
jump off it you just kind of break a
neck
right
um that's why it's less that would be
less romantic
uh another question from anonymous in
both of your work tone is so critically
important and specific sandy in
approaching the idiot as an adaptation
how much do you think about tone is the
goal to preserve the tone of the novel
or to in some way make the story your
own that brings a different tone with it
um it's both it's being true to the
novel
um stone and ella because i know her now
and
and um to bring out things that she
might it might not might not have been
so apparent in the novel just in talking
to her that
we know it's there but to draw these
themes
um but to always um keep it
funny
but also
um
you know but also tell the story of this
this girl's um you know journey growing
up and
in growing up it's it's there's always
going to be you know slightly
heartbreaking stuff as well um so that's
that's the
the tonal thing you're trying to do with
this kind of strange little hopscotch
between funny and and sad
and and one of the constant questions i
have during that that's asked throughout
this um
my screenplay anyway is um whether it's
funny or is that because the things
every scene can go either way right but
somebody slips i actually have sweat
lana raising a hand in class and saying
wait a minute is that supposed to be
funny or sad um oh that's so great
yeah but that's that's that's the thing
about your book is like is it funny or
sad that seems to be the constant
question and that's my question of life
itself always
so um that's the question i ask in the
movie as well
for sandy coming from rachel
uh trying to think what else rhymes with
shirkers and
what else you're working on any clues
rachel rosen that must be rachel wasn't
um i um no no well berserkers but i'm
not gonna go there
okay workers
workers yeah
um maybe they're selling with gherkin
i just i like to have sons eating corny
shones and i wonder if gherkin can
lurk her working
um so so you said the statues do not
appear in the sequel either or
no there's probably some nuts in it
somewhere
because like the the quarantine has been
a time of increased nut anxiety because
like i have to like probably not
consumption in your home nut consumption
yeah yeah it's a big like you're you're
nuts.com yeah customers i'm their top
customer yeah
a question from jesse the idiot is
strongly influenced by russian
literature sandy do you share ellis love
for rich russian literature and what is
it like finding finding cinematic
equivalents for such a wonderfully
literary book
um i do not share her love i mean not to
that extent um even i don't anymore
but i do i do respect that and i do um
pay well i i do pay close attention to
how she
she comes to it so it's it's it's it's
um
we have a lot of references throughout
the movie version as well that's kind of
like you know how she thinks about the
world in terms of russian lit it's also
in the movie because that's just true to
how she thinks about things
um and um in terms of cinematic i it's
hard to
to say um
specifically
um
but you know there there are little
there are aspects of this that are a
little bit like
call me by your name um just because it
ends up in europe um and the world opens
up and it's a period film but it's also
very different so it's really hard for
to think of a comp because i think it's
because the idiot is such a singular
book that when you treat it we have to
find a slightly more singular i mean
just a different way of doing it then
it's
it's um
it's hard to think of an exact calm i
mean because then you start one you
start you start mentioning a lot of arty
european movies uh or or movies that
that people may not um find
so appealing um but but that i do um
like my one of my favorite movies is uh
joe kim tries uh reprise
you know and and um but you know like
you you mentioned that movie and people
draw a blank um so it's not a comp but
it's it's a very talky movie about very
smart young people and there aren't that
many movies made about smart young
people unfortunately so you know we
might have to invent
our own thing
another question for sandy
says sandy in a new york times magazine
piece you were quoted as saying i'm
mostly not interested in thinking and
working within the asian american sphere
or addressing its issues and you talk
instead of mainstreaming asian american
interests could you elaborate on that a
little bit
wow okay
um
well
i think that most interesting stories
out there aren't going to necessarily be
just
asian american stories and i want to you
know tell interesting stories so
that's what i mean by that um
um out of context that sounds a little
aggressive
um but i think you know what i mean
yeah
um
a question from rona for both of you are
you still working on casting
would you be open to extras from this
particular audience asking for a friend
oh yeah we're working on everything the
world is just starting to open up again
so we're now kind of like
actively um kind of pursuing
trying to get this movie made um so it's
early days yet but yeah we will we are
thinking about counseling with thinking
about all kinds of things at the moment
um
it's early days
but exciting
um
so inclu
closing question we always ask people uh
at the end of this conversation what
what film have you been watching lately
uh during the pandemic but instead that
given where we just were in the
conversation
uh is there a russian novel
each of you would recommend
or a movie
any anything you that has
caught your eye
recently
i mean i think that sandy and i are both
over the russians by now
i think we might be
yeah cynthia are you do you i i think
the closest thing i can think of well
not really close but i mean just like
the crazy guy in his head
um
you know um novel that i just finished
listening to actually is uh philip
roth's um sabbath's theater that i
listen to on audiobook which is i i have
to i cannot recommend highly enough
because it's such a deranged it's a
deranged book but it's also a deranged
read because all the voices are read by
this one man so he's doing all even like
the female lover um like you know all
these like intimate scenes bedroom
scenes in in this very frenzied voice
and that's just very highly entertaining
um that's my closest fashion novel is
that the one with the like directing
like she's like masturbating and he's
directing like a yeah
yes
like um yeah
i got a book um to to read that is going
to come out in february which is the
first novel by
a weaker writer to be translated into
english like this muslim population in
in china that um so he's been
disappeared since he published the novel
and he's like in a camp somewhere and
nobody knows who he is and i was like
gonna read the novel anyway because it's
like a a good deed for like the you know
the ethnic turkic people but it's really
good it's like it's a really good book
the guy it's called the back streets and
the author's name is perhaps
um it's coming out in february from
columbia university press and there's a
production where the translator the
translator is like a postdoc at
princeton or somewhere and he went out
there to like to xinjiang where i'm not
quite sure how to say it and he he met
this guy and he talks about him and he
just sounds like a complete oddball like
he just he loves kamu and he's like he's
read the plague like speaking of the
pink hotel he's read the plague like 9
000 times and he wrote this club it's
kind of like the stranger it's like
first person and it's kind of like right
funny and also in the guy's head and
yeah there's just an amazing part where
he's like he he runs into some guy who's
talking about how they have to like
murder the whole
minority weaker population the guys like
chop chop chop chop chop all the people
from the six cities and the guy's like
well all the people in the six cities
that's like this million people so like
if you were really gonna chop them all
you wouldn't have time to sort them into
friends or enemies so you really have to
chop all of them and then the contact of
the machete with the face would take
this amount of time so you multiply that
by this million and you've got several
years and like is this guy really going
to live that like the whole operation
rounding people up he like estimates
it's going to take five years he's like
is this guy going to even live 25 years
like look at his face he looks really
angry man i don't know he might be a
goner it's just like there's something
really like i don't know i i'm really
loving this book
um
one final question somebody asked uh
sorry sorry i missed the name of the
film sandy mentioned with the smart
young people can you oh um reprise by um
well a reprise um
by joe kim tria
um t-r-i-e-r
um
yeah i think he might have been a that
might have been a film independent
spirit award nominee or should have been
it's one of my favorite films ever
well sandy and ella thank you so much
this has been a great conversation um
it's very nice to be a fly on the wall
and to jump in at the end but thank you
both so much thank you so much and i
have to say i i think you would you you
would have to agree that ella should try
to do that theatrical monologue thing
that you that that that korean platform
we should do a joint act and these
questions were so wonderful thank you to
the audience and to the everyone who
asked questions yeah thank you so much
for inviting us this is so fun
it's great
again
for anyone watching who hasn't gotten
these novels go get them read them by
them
and i can't wait to see the film